hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay we need to go we
need to go right now
to somewhere kill a dragon shut up
[ __ ]
alright we're off to kill dragon because
this lady that I'm supposed to trust all
of a sudden tells me that I need to
prove that I'm really the Dragonborn I
don't know why I couldn't have just
shouted in her face kinda girl we can
travel together split up and meet there
I meet you there cuz I can fast travel
I'm a badass who what the hell
I Hrothgar oh I need to return the horn
oh let me let me return the horn first
cuz I think they give me more training
or something I don't know this is past
the point where I've actually been in
the game so I don't know up up up up up
the stairs to the old guys well guys
living all alone in the mountains where
are ya
are you you you doc didn't do thing shut
up okay over here
where y'all me our old man ah there you
are sleeping get up you've retrieved the
Horn of yoga room yes I have well done
yeah now past all the trial okay
fantastic Oh someone said something
about um putting a torch I think I
grabbed it torch a long time ago
nope I got a tankard that's base core ID
Hey
no torches okay what I mean it is time
for us to recognize you formally as
Dragonball okay fantastic let's go I
need to kill a dragon you know being the
dragon born and all old man bear hurry
up if you know what's good for you why
is everything stealable in here or why
is why can't I take anything on the
Dragonborn this should be my place too
right right right
whatever y'all douches come on run with
your feet says oh here we go come here
Wulfgar
yeah lydian da ah
FUS ro dah ah I like it I like your
laugh oh you so slow man you just had to
be in beds get Lydia get out of the way
Lydia I swear Lydia gah
alright let's go what am i doing there
we go
okay give me give me your soul
got that receive the Greybeards greeting
uh-huh we would speak to you're speaking
to me now stand between us and prepare
yourself fuel can withstand the
unbridled voice of the gravy aha ready
good talk to me Oh Oh Oh yell alrighty
then call me bad names in another
language
what about Lydia there she seems to be
getting some of the brunt of it
dad Lydia's tough she may be a little
thick in the head but she's tough all
right
Dover key you have tasted the loss of
the grave taste it man passed through
unscathed uh-huh high Hrothgar is open
does that mean I can have everything in
here please can I steal everything oh my
god yeah mine yeah mine mine mine all
mine
it books here worth having a flute yeah
I'll take that
see Oh food mine you'll starve mine mine
mine mine mine lots of potions of
regeneration I like it
ah all right whoo cheese wheels mine
mine see here mine mine
anything else spirit of nirn oh is that
it's worth some I'll take it
see all right that's it taking all your
[ __ ] man what are you gonna do about it
gimme mine or mine mine see what we got
here
Oh Oh your prize puts possessions mine
oh what's that oh you got your little
death bell by your bed mine
what's this mine mine mine mine mine
mine mine mine anything in here
now take your clothes too and yeah and
this candlestick couldn't pass this by
me there we go and this and this and
this and this
what's that another potion regeneration
okay all mine all right
let's go we got a kill dragon now that
I've got only break your [ __ ] ah
like it I'm still a little it um
interested as why the voice of the shout
isn't like an Argonian voice I don't
know if it's like the same way for like
a Khajiit er because last time I played
an ordinates it sounded like that okay
anyway um I gotta go all the way over
the air okay maybe I can like take it
yeah I can probably take something to
Windhelm was that it windhelm I don't
know I don't know I'm just a Dragonborn
what do I know
uh-huh
among the Companions most treasure
artifacts are the blood whatever fine
gone yeah windhelm windhelm hey stable
boy tag me - oh that dead guy still
there I wonder why he's naked I can take
you to any of the hole where do you want
to go win him oh now you can go to a
place let's be off you can do that
before you dick ever bender window shut
up the city I don't care shut if you're
gonna talk a little a there I'm gonna
stab you through the navel lucha dragon
something I won't kill with my fists
what with my sword
alright Windhelm um this way come on
Lydia Lydia get the lead out we were
going gah
Lydia I swear
alright are you still there Lydia
come on iron ore wait someone said there
was like a trick to it if you like
havier you have this equipped and you
swing at it it'll like go ten times as
fast ha ha ha
big one yeah well that's actually kind
of cool I didn't know that that'll make
it a lot easier yeah
still great sir rush you want some goat
yeah you better run
not fast enough no man ja goat me
tonight
leg of goat just the one leg goat F for
that I know of
go the wrong way um lots of stuff um I
gotta go up the mountain did I go so I
went around missed my exit
did I wait what I don't know we're
trying to find a dragon who knows where
I go oh there it is there it is oh
what's that let the lady okay I'll get
ready dragon your earth
suck on this yeah that is her that's
totally the lady come on
what whoa hello
keep your head down let's see what it
does let's see what it does I manage of
you huh wait where are you where are you
buh-buh-bah do you see me now
douche don't be such a baby let's go
let's go goodbye get me give me that who
another one that I don't know much no
that's nice
um Bob Loblaw nothing all right nothing
nothing at all they're the only dead
body come on buddy
what are you doing son look good here
ah just as bad as I do another bit like
mine all your stuff is mine
um yeah did that and another still great
sword out Oh bone dragon
I got ya come here Oh getting the jump
on you oh let me put off let me get the
UH
where's his skin going then now I'm
going to whoa Oh suck it down get you
all mine oh my Mykel Mykel Mykel Mykel
Mykel Mykel Oh what no no fancy jump on
the dragon I I did go to bub give me
your soul yeah
you press now compress Lydia was across
long
you impress now baby huh what I'm
looking a lot more handsome aren't I and
wrong I sucked up dragon soul right out
of his body
dragon one more proof whoops no hard
feelings eh I owe you some answers don't
ya
go ahead whatever you want to know
nothing held back nothing who are you
one of the last members of the blades a
very long time ago the blades were
dragon slayers okay and we served the
dragon oh oh so you served me years
since the last dragon born Emperor the
blades have been searching for a purpose
me now that dragons are coming back our
purpose is clear again ah we need to
stop it okay well you know about them
come on a damn thing
well aren't you useless surprised is you
to find that big black dragon here oh
you're such a what's our next move first
thing we need to do is figure out who's
behind the dreadnought Sal more the
Thalmor are okay that if they aren't
involved they'll know who is uh-huh I
know who the Thalmor are there those
elves that tried to cut off my head in
the beginning of the game see here we go
nothing solid yet but my gut tells me it
can't be anybody the Empire had captured
over it uh-huh the war was basically
over then a dragon attacks all frickin
escapes and the war is back on okay and
now the dragons are attacking everywhere
indiscriminately they are Skyrim is
weakened the Empire is weakened
who else gains from that but the Thalmor
I don't know do they who are the thumb
or a faction that rules the Aldmeri
Dominion uh-huh the ones who almost
destroy the Empire during the Great War
30 years back well those douches there's
no worse enemy to humankind into
okay the Empire barely survived the last
wha the Thalmor don't intend to lose oh
when they go up against me they're gonna
lose everything alright so we need to
find out about okay we could get into
the that problem is that place is locked
up tighter than a misers pearl they
could teach me a few things about
paranoia so I need you to I'm a I'm an
Argonian there's no way this my penis
comes in I'll need some talk maybe back
in Riverwood if I'm not back when you
get there
wait for me I shouldn't be long okay
keep an eye on the sky this is only
going to get worse right whatever I
don't care
whew what a lovely way to die so in your
ass to all your enemies way to go there
no one wants to dies on their die on
their hands and knees that's a darn
shame Sal LOC near that's the Loch near
our AMA finded town
wait where'd she go she's gone like
magic maybe she was magic that was her
ah torch
that'd be handy all right um I think
there are any other bodies just this one
oh she's running down the road okay all
right those nothing else are now I'm
going to go back to the town sell some
crap sales and crap Giuliano's is the
god of wisdom and logic revered by
Wizards he has a shrine in the temple of
the Divine's in solitude last night I
gotta go sleep you you wants them huh
yeah yeah my way where us guess I can
cheese my board for you do how are you
why are you all in the street night out
go to bed
oh you don't need to do nothing for me
to your face in why are you looking a
baby once I've made enough money trading
with the cozy Caravan no I'm going to
buy the bed yes so yeah are you so ready
whoa back off lady oh did you need
something
do you are you're not the innkeeper
where's the ink you know you Brian it's
what can I get
I need a room sure thing it's yours for
today all right come on Lydia right this
way come on Liv and you don't need to
show me why you again when he met the
shieldmaiden Matilda who said oh you
talkin you lie and you drink all the
booze back who's that oh wow she's in
full-on who's that way I got it I got
like real oh dear accelerating on time
Hawking you're lying in your show there
no I think you can go blade a blade with
me Oh seconds oh and why not 100 gold
says I knock your height oh-ho-ho-ho-ho
fists no weapon oh holy hell yeah let's
oh whoops oh not uh let's do this he's
gonna glass again come on come on
Oh what now huh yeah you ain't got
nothing on me oh yeah
Oh beat the crap out of you oh oh not so
unbroken now are you
mmm no the red I don't care about you i
won give me my goal right now that's
what I call a pop yeah I did your know
200 gold
there you are best fight you've ever had
that that's the strange masochistic
alright anyway come on Lydia it's time
for bed
oh come on Lydia oh yeah yeah yeah I'm
going to bed without you you you watch
TV I don't care what do I care what I
care go to bed alone oh all right that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you everyone so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
Oh Lydia slimy Oh bye bye